[Music]
deutschland would suspend them Germany
has to change if it wants to master the
refugee crisis according to Lamia cod or
Islam scholar author religion teacher
and an important voice in the debate
here in Germany about Islam and
xenophobia Lamia door is our guest this
week hello and welcome everyone to the
interview I'm Alexandra phenomena Miska
door Chancellor Angela Merkel says
Germany will remain Germany despite the
refugee crisis you say Germany must
change that we need a new sense of who
we are why is that the store chance
especially for my Germany will remain
Germany of course particularly with its
approach to life this open and
pluralistic society but when I say we
need a new sense of we of who we are I
don't mean we should scrap what we
already have but rather think about
adding new elements especially
considering that immigration is indeed a
part of our German history a society
that is home to many immigrants needs to
embrace a range of points of view that
is why I say we need a new sense of who
we are as Germans one that the majority
and all the minorities living in this
country can agree upon so we can find
common ground on which to base our lives
here long as I'd hear about the dust
that's what school did a bee attack you
on the leaves while I repeat that does
not mean rejecting established
traditions far from it I don't see why I
should not live a German life but why
not also ask other people who have lived
here for 30 40 50 years what they think
constitutes a good life even I believe
them throughout the park it's quite an
offer and you also say Germans have an
obligation here but can't a majority
expect new arrivals to adapt and to
integrate into clear of course the
majority can expect that but still for
that to happen the majority has to offer
something as well it's hard for
minorities arriving in a new country to
adapt to or blend in with the majority
if the latter does not extend a
welcoming hand
it has to do its part to make it
possible for minorities to integrate
that is why I talked about obligations
the majority has to be ready to value
and accept people who want to belong to
their society and say to them we
appreciate that let's go down this road
together so immigration is not a one-way
street that's not just an empty phrase
if you got yours in that sacred kind of
mantra Don's a good camera in your
opinion hostility to islam is on the
rise in Germany have you as a Muslim
encountered that yourself become yep in
my video mine yes of course time and
again that's a thoughtful and recently
more so than ever because so much
attention has been paid to my background
my Syrian roots my foreign roots which
make me an outsider in some people's
eyes all these are pointers it moves
even been it also has to do with the
fact that I'm Muslim it conjures up all
kinds of stereotypes for example that we
Muslims tend to be violent that we're
all subversive and want to undermine
societies oh I give you Andrew them the
fact that I'm a woman also plays a role
here every end either Indies arbitrator
on the oil how is that manifested
doesn't jump higher you in verbal abuse
for one thing I get emails or posts on
Facebook or tweets that are horribly
aggressive are faithful the most
disgusting and sexist abuse mental maths
sometimes accompanied by sexual
fantasies it's not existed from a simple
subtitle 65 others hinder our corporate
and that is clearly because I'm a woman
sometimes they call into question my
really being a Muslim some say I'm
probably secretly a Jew who knows why in
car Google food only go globe origin we
have a sauna copter hidden in Berkeley
sky while I'm over my only because I
have never set of ice collegians you're
a teacher of religious education but
you've now taken a leave of absence
because you fear for your safety and the
safety of your pupils did some event
trigger this I'm a threat perhaps that
made you decide you'd had enough
the exact time it's gated snake man was
talking to zero from for her it had been
brewing for a while even before my book
came out exits were published and the
amount of hate mail to sword the answer
I'm room for mother really horrible
abuse and hate that made me very nervous
it was directed at me and was less about
the issues on my nap ezell infest my
flawless Vinnie gone tema so it was
really personal yes and in part about
the issues how could I as a foreigner
which I'm not dare to criticize Germans
and demand things of them for the record
I am German I have thought a lot about
why some people have such a hard time
with me I suspect it has to do with my
identity I am a German and a Muslim a
Muslim and a German for me that's
entirely self evident there is no
contradiction me thirsty does Joaquin
arias ball which GABA Donna but it
bothers a wide range of different groups
Islamists and right-wing populist also
can't deal with it with my kind of
identity they project onto me all the
rage and disgust and hatred they feel
towards an open pluralistic society in
being an often employ an example the
critics accuse you of exaggerating in
order to boost sales of your book what
do you say to that couldnt was sagging
see that's all this is blanco who knows
that's nonsense i'm not exaggerating at
all come on like yahoo email for years
now i have been getting really horrible
emails but recently i've had to report
five or six miles a day to the
authorities asking them to press charges
emails from photo sexy moves wider line
so i don't consider it an exaggeration
at all as one as it evolved quite the
contrary i get woken up with death
threats and hail Hitler's we're coming
to gas you you loser you are really a
jew and will do to you and your family
and your children what they did to the
Jews back then whooping a mortal on
that's how a typical morning began for
me after that I would go off to teach
and it was really hard for me in the
classroom and it hasn't stopped so no I
do not exaggerate nor do I consider
myself a victim
I don't like the fact that many Muslims
see themselves as victims in this
society isn't your monster you're
somebody who takes a stand in public
have you ever thought of no longer
making any public appearances yeah
imported all yes I have of course it's
also terrible and disturbing you
sometimes want to hide because it's just
too much but that's not an option it
would mean these haters or critics had
achieved their goal though you can't
really call them critics it's more than
criticism they want to silence people
like me who stand up for a pluralistic
democracy and the rule of law and the
Constitution that underpins our open
society I don't want them to succeed so
I had to think about what I could still
do what makes sense and what I can face
emotionally it was clear that it would
be difficult to continue teaching the
school is a public space and everybody
in Germany now knows where i teach and I
have to protect my pupils so it was
clear I couldn't continue teaching what
I did you tryna valediction a good
coffin does mr. Mahone sukin your
parents are from Syria you were born in
allen in Westphalia what was it like
growing up there quite relaxed really
although I remember when I was three my
parents would tell me as I went to
kindergarten you are different suck my
little margin aquila gardening but they
didn't attach a particular value to it
different but not better or worse I felt
okay about being different different as
in you are Arab so there was some sense
of belonging give us our debts a
ghoulish guy but then at kindergarten
they would say you are Turkish you are a
foreigner was also not cute that was
hard for me I started early on to think
about these things and about my place in
the world and I came up with different
answers in different periods in my life
at times I was a bit more Arab in a bit
less German at others i was a bit more
german unless arab at some point I said
simply I am both like in equal measure I
don't see any
tradition anymore I have worked out who
I am and of course it was a process it
doesn't happen overnight because each
group would say you belong here or there
or wherever but i have my identity now
and I'm content it feels completely
normal but it took a while you're a
practicing Muslim were you brought up
religious you once said your parents
were rather conservative team well my
parents values have always been very
conservative and still long which is
okay and they taught us to have
conservative values as well but they are
still open minded they did not reject
the wider society they always understood
our children were born in Germany they
live here go to school here are
socialized here at home and outside the
home we can't shield them from the world
in fact they never really wanted to they
were ready to compromise from the start
it was clear we would do stuff and join
in and get an education but they didn't
want us to forget the other components
of our identity it is port on the Arab
routes being a Muslim being a woman my
parents had their own ideas about how he
should be educated but they didn't mind
if I didn't accept everything they
wanted me to although I think that's
true for parents around the world and
children don't always do exactly what
their parents want copies of it let's
give me a [ __ ] naldo's Muhammad's again
it quite as new champion a modern
reformed version of Islam what kind of
Islam belongs in Germany it prob won't
offer laws and open-minded Islam an
Islam that is willing to engage in
dialogue that manifests it's warm
hearted compassionate side and that
worships a loving merciful God but it is
up to each believer to decide how he or
she wants to live to practice the
religion in everyday life whether or not
to pray or faster wear a headscarf for
example I have found my personal path
and to some degree you can see that in
the way I dress but you can't reduce it
to external things I would not say women
who wear a
scarf are more religious than those who
don't nor would I say that we Muslims
are better than or superior to people of
another religion or who are not
religious at all I would say is llamas
probably the religion that suits me best
but I don't believe that it needs to be
the right one for everyone else in the
country not at all least of all about
Tokyo satisfy a year new zealand's I'm
mr. Duvall finish at the end of our DW
interview we always ask our guests to
complete three sentences so here's the
first one by the time my son is an adult
Germany will be more open-minded I being
a Muslim woman this is hard right now
because I feel I'm always caught in the
middle the proverbial darkness of the
people in Westphalia where I was born is
actually very charming Lamia khador
thank you my pleasure